violence et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur ds que vous allez bien avec
détourne apprendre la politesse à prix
800 mille vidéos aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour jouer à deux petits jeux
le premier midi ait voilà joe stack
s'ennuie lâché qui ne nous quittera
jamais presse passe tout continue hop
c'est parti ça alors c'est un petit juas
amusant même si le principe est un peu
bizarre
cet homme déjà extrêmement mal quelque
chose tu il va bien sûr évacuer suffit
de cliquer sur go poupe
voilà je comprends pas trop pourquoi ça
à moi je crois que cet arrêt rico dans
les traileurs en fait jusqu'à moi
j'avais tellement mal que dieu quoi
voilà le but c'est d'affoler les gens en
voiture à kaka sur un trottoir cet
affreux voilà c'est ça ce peut-être
changé dieu finalement donc là du coup
je veux gagner 2 sordo là et je peux
ensuite acheter des petits investisseurs
qui permettent de modifier la taille la
largeur caractéristiques de mon cas car
ce gars là effectivement être très très
mal digéré alors vous aussi que vous
digéré très mal faite bien kaka du haut
d'un toit ça soulage extrêmement mieux
il paraît aux [ __ ] j'aimerais bien
avec sa taille spin sur la tête d'un de
quelqu un peu un premier impact de votre
caca et plus large
voilà un piment ces parties cop ou aps
bref al mabhouh sur la tête de quelqu'un
c'est affreux ouais ça qu'on fait pour
eux
non mais je suis qu un cac à masirah et
y en a partout des cacas du caca de
chien sur les trottoirs au roi on a fait
mille dollars dont tout le monde se met
à péter en fait c'est hyper protégé
comme maladie basse et voilà voilà
google est bon là on le sait a le lait
permet à ton caca de faire des plus
grosses flaques c'est parti là bas puis
sur sa [ __ ] n'y avait rien des
verriers en a fait un joli rebond mais
y'a rien à la glisse et voile a glissé
tous
non mais j'ai juste fait une flaque la
houille absolue aux personnes qui
passent quoi ces débilités à le maïs
permanenciers cas non importé plus gros
score et d'argent c'est très bien c'est
parti et 6 où il est tombé sur le
trottoir le voit juste là comme ça voilà
parfait vers des as du maïs en plus de
deux ans voilà on a fait une flaque en
travers n'importe qui qui passe tombe
attention tous ces gens vont tomber oui
quelle stratégie incroyable est sous une
voiture ça fait quoi sauf un accident de
voiture attendait on n'a pas testé bien
là comme ça hop
oh oui oh oui puis du coup elles vont
elles vont bien écraser les gens tout ça
à cause d'un mec qui fait tiquer malades
quoi et ça les connaît s'y faire caca du
notw a rapporté 3590 dollar
on sait tous genres d'un taux
actuellement c'est bien ça c'est
l'apport pour accéder aux escaliers là
où la salle de bahreïn mais c'était on
préfère rester sur le haut d'un toit et
je suis sûr si on est un oiseau là qui
passe sauvegardés
je suis sûr qu'ils en aient un oiseau on
a vraiment énormément de points tandis
je vais attendre
oh [ __ ] presse j'ai cru j'ai cru jégo
qui avait lobé kt et en pensant que
c'est un petit poisson mais non vous
savez c'est notre but là ce nouvel
objectif à on n'avait pas de vitesse pas
là j'ai touché au kk maman parce que tu
crois vraiment elle toujours qu'il m'a
entendu à ce jeu doivent de se dire que
j'ai un gros problème
un hymne aux problèmes on a accompli
vraiment quelque chose agréable
aujourd'hui vous êtes fiers de vous
reprocher peut-être eu l'idée attendait
là sur la plaque d'égout up
oh bah voilà 500 points qui je vous
avais dit et on va rebondir sur un
parasol pour faire un combo 360o hatch
mott attendait au qatar elle choque
énormément mais nous monga a presque je
réussirai à faire montre xshot 360 après
le rebond 167 ça va ah mais regarde je
peux sauter ou là une formalité
on a pu noter que chante après 20
minutes à à chier d'un toit quoi dans ma
vie est nul pour fêter ça voilà on a
tous fait finalement on peut le dire on
a tout fait tout ça à cause de cet homme
ou cette femme mais on sait pas trop si
c'est un homme ou une femme qui n'a pas
de pied en plus de ça c'était ça qu'il a
mangé ses pieds sur ça qu'il révèle au
but bref il est l'heure de passer au jeu
suivant paint the trade
voilà un jeu un peu bad ass arrière
assez violent mais bon vu les graphismes
ça devrait pas vous choquer à moins que
vous soyez qubo fob qui est tout à fait
possible
alors ces gars sont fous et je pense
qu'ils sont sur moi t'es foutu ils ont
encerclé le bâtiment il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire désolé tu touche pas à
mon gars au match aux enjeux peut
bloquer regarder avec mes gros biceps
qui tu vas faire un organe bouteille
pardon excusez moi pardon vous trichez
les gars je pars pour une bouteille moi
j'ai mieux l'échec la sortie non je peux
pas non aux plats dans ta tête
on est pas mal sans déconner on
attendait j'ai une idée de fou
euh pause merde excuse moi parlons faut
que je prenne ça voilà au [ __ ] c'est
génial ya qu est ce qu il ya à l étage
ils sont désarmés sont des armes j'ai
pris le chien
voilà c'est quoi ça c'est incroyable
c'est pouvoir spécial vous êtes
j'appelle un style peur en gros qui est
quelque part sur un toit ou sur un
billet remous sur une chaise même y at
il quelqu'un a encore un honneur il ont
appelé des renforts
comment allons-nous faire ce qu'on peut
accéder là dedans s'il vous plaît non
chers qui avait une super arme mais oui
regardez au yen à il faut qu'on accepte
à la porte est ouverte aux non la porte
est ouverte à cause de toi
excuse-moi bon je voulais prendre ce
canal pour taper sur l'autre mais c'est
un peu glauque jeu casta boutés contre
le mur moi non
oui ça a marché et la fille devaient des
deux buts niais à aa
et là attention le point spécial tissus
en [ __ ] avec le sable qui veulent au
ralenti ça va être beau ça va être beau
beau j'ai pas voulu ce style peur mais
il est vraiment bien cachés regardez
comme c'est beau vous aussi qu'est ce
que vous croyez à les tirs lors dessus
s'il te plaît oh la la c'est tellement
beau alors je commence vers la batterie
mais oui on peut faire la batterie ça
vous dit qu'on fasse ça ensemble un
petit peu allez on se relaxe
c'est beau c'est de jouer je vous
regarde pas mal pas mal pas mal à
arrêter c'est bon on joue aux boules
auplata est bien dans un bar le mec tout
le monde et après lui et lui tout ce
qu'il fait c'est de lancer des boules
sur la tête des gens j'ai une chope de
bière ou quoi aller c'est ma tournée
mais chez moi on a fait le tour déjà il
reste quoi hélas pas grand chose oh oui
le tabouret bonne fac bonne foi car oui
moi je dis toi un peu de chacun c'est
simple c'est quoi ça ça sent j'ai même
passé une poêle sait qu on sait même pas
non mais c'est pas toi à l'échec à ton
tour tu commences à toi ensuite suivant
tu es mort bâtard avec un stop motion
j'ai pas d'où la balle bien mais je m'en
bats les steaks vous allez tout aux
essais des tabourets presque hier
moi j'annonce se mange annonce la
couleur voilà je vais pas dire flamants
roses alors je lance un tabouret
tabouret voyez par exemple achète ça
c'est radical c'est presque violent
et ça ça c'est vraiment le cheveu ça
dans tous les jours voilà même dans
mario kart voilà quelqu'un me double je
fais avec mes doigts c'est terminé c'est
la forme d'un résistant à gagner tu peux
nous répondre c'est la fin je vous aime
tous genres et je vous fais une petite
chanson tard tu meurs je pourrais pas
tous vous tuer mais le premier d'entre
vous qui m'attaque je le tuerais sma
punchline si l'on sait faire peur et
vous voyez vous voyez sur dans
l'hésitation maintenant voilà je t'avais
dit et si on skie amour parce qu'elle
vous fait aller chacun son tour la
batterie chacun à son tour vous êtes
inscrit au club music ou pas bon si vous
n'êtes pas assez vous blessez bordel
c'est ma patrie bon ballastières aux non
à la déception c'est des basques ne
faisait pourtant il est oui je joue à
l'hectare county qu elle est alors c'est
ces gens pour inscrire la ils ont volé
tous les instruments du club musique du
coup n'a plus rien on à l'agencé dia fin
de cette petite vidéo assez courte 1 2 2
juin des mais je voulais vraiment voulu
monter parce que je trouve vraiment cool
j'ai soir chez vous a plu si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude je le dit pas assez souvent
mais vous êtes top et merci de regarder
mes vidéos voilà c'est bien de le
rappeler tout le temps quand même ça
fait super plaisir et ça me donne encore
plus envie de faire des vidéos je vous
remercierai jamais assez pour ça comme
d'habitude on se retrouve très vite au
club musique jazz monde pis